what can you tell us about uh that
uh source magazine cover was everyone
there at the same time yep
what was that like it was a great day i
played dominoes with jay prince um
senior
and uh
we was on a ranch you know that was one
of the inspirations to me you know
buying a ranch and cattle
um so just being on the ranch and
hearing about the ranch and just being
there because what was on that cover of
his face bro slim
pow
chameleon millionaire
pimp c bun b
chingo bling which was random but i
don't think he was on the cover i think
he was on the inside yeah you had to
open it oh you had to open it yeah okay
because it was it was the cover was like
one of those fold-outs
i still have a magazine
damn but i remember him being there yeah
cause like the ones i got i got i still
got some copies of that in my studio but
that particular one i don't think
maybe he was on the other side maybe i
don't remember yeah i think it was the
inside but but yeah everybody was there
bro it was a cold day
that's what i had on the ferry it was a
cold ass [ __ ] day and um
we did some kind of like pasta mic
freestyle that same day too it was cool
man i mean
it was cold was probably the last day
that all those people were together all
at once huh man
when you put it like that probably so
it's a lot of people together yeah yeah
probably so because we lost pmc long
live pmc yeah smoke sound [ __ ] in
memory of pmc
yeah that was a that was a big moment
because i just it encapsulated just kind
of right the movement that was going on
at the time definitely uh
why do you think that movement
didn't have a lot of longevity
commercially because it felt like there
was like a three or four year window
where it was like it and then it kind of
just started to you know
i don't know if it was g unit you know
running with [ __ ] or it just just hip
hop kind of shifted shifted right
um i know part of the reason
is
what's the word evolving right
every coast every town has their own
lingo their own slang words that they
say things that they do
so for us you know the candy paint the
double cups the diamond teeth
that's us right that's our culture like
we live it's in us it's not a fad for us
right so
sometimes a fad for the rest of the
country right so yeah to sum up yeah
they thought it was a fad and so
everybody started getting grills where
they're talking you know funny can't
really talk and just
you know double cups all this stuff that
we started and um
so man it's just like some people didn't
want to keep hearing about candy paint
poppin trunks grills you know what i
mean
and then um
at the same time
some artists like
okay if you make a record that's
about a certain topic right can it
it goes you know gold or whatever the
case may be pretty you know plenty
fanfare
you're going to
replicate that people are going to be in
your ear
you need another one of those right so
then you go back in the studio you try
to make another one of those back then
yeah right so it's like you're probably
on your head like we need another
sunshine right right